So what does this mean for the problem sizes that we can expect to handle?
I'm going to give you a little quiz here so that you can develop a feeling for that.
Assume that we want to consider, at most, 1 billion possible solutions
for an NP complete problem, 1 billion different assignments of 0 and 1 to the vertices.
So what I would like you to do is to figure out the maximum problem size that we can handle
using these best known search trees under this condition here.
We want to consider, at most, 1 billion different solutions.
So please enter your answer here in these boxes.
What I would like you to do for this box here is use this algorithm.
For this box here I would like you to use this one here.
And for comparison I would like you to figure out 2 more.
One is 1.1 to the power of N, and one is 2 to the power of N.
So there's actually 5 different answers here.